when we sat down here last year you
talked about data and analytics and how
it played such a big role for you and
your team that's only gotten bigger in
the last year in the world of precision
medicine and connected fitness how are
you using it now well I mean now
everything there's two elements one how
do you acquire the data right so we went
from just fit bits with basic sensors
and heart monitors and blood pressure
monitors and pulse monitor you know to
base things to now everybody's trying to
push the envelope for new types of
sensors you know new ways to measure
blood arm whatever it may be and so new
sources of data is the first element and
then the second part of it is your brain
right the real upside and analytics from
a sports perspective how do you train
the brain how do you analyze the brain
how do you deal with issues that aren't
obvious because you can have all the
physical talent in the world we can put
you you know in better shape than a six
million dollar man but if your brain is
not where it should be if your mindset
isn't right none of that matters but a
year later are you actually seeing
results on the court yeah you know we've
got a product called axon that I
invested in and all it does is train and
retrain and train your brain right so it
went from okay let's test for basketball
IQ see how quickly they can identify
plays too all right these are different
chain scenarios if this then that can
you identify and how quickly you were
able to make the right decision and
we're able we've been taking our rookie
Justin Anderson and some of our other
rookies and just running them through
these drills and you can see their
progress and improvement over the course
of the years